so you want to be a ninja badass and
throw shuriken z' into people's butts
and stab them in their faces well Genji
is your cyborg man and overwatch is your
game I'm Chris waters here with Mike
McCarty to talk you through this tricky
character definitely you'll see a lot of
him giving you a lot of trouble it's
gonna make you want to play him here's
how to do it like Genji's a ninja so
play like a ninja stay mobile but be
patient a lot of his abilities rely on
you using them correctly in terms of
timing you don't want to deflect bullets
when no one's shooting at you there's
nothing to deflect you don't want to
dash someone and miss with your sword
and not recharge the attack there's a
lot of nuance to this character it's
tough but once you start mastering him
people gonna hate you yeah tough in
terms of he can be a real force to be
reckoned with not in terms of health
he's a real squishy dude so hit and run
is definitely the strategy just cuz
you're sort of focusing in on one enemy
doesn't mean you have to kill them in
the first engagement do some damage dart
away know where a health pack is or just
disorient them as to where you're gonna
show up next to and then hit him again
and here's how you're gonna be hitting
them first off you got your shuriken one
your primary fire shoots three straight
in a line the other spreads them out
pretty simple difference here one is
good for distance and one is good for
close up yeah and also the 303 round
burst is better for one character and
then the spread is good for tanks up
close because you can hit all three
right away without aiming as much but
it's also good against groups if you're
just trying to thin out the Horde and a
straight line they stay accurate at a
distance so if there's a turret or a
sniper that's unaware of your position
throw some shuriken Zaid them because
one of your biggest roles is to Harry
the enemy and to make them wonder where
you are and where you're going to strike
from next if you're chipping away at a
turret that doesn't see you cool if you
are chipping away at a turret that does
see you you are in danger of getting
melted down by a bastion real quick this
is where some tricky deflection can come
into play the deflection is probably his
most important ability not only can it
protect you but it can also just turn
people's attacks back on them and
there's also a few second gap between
when you start an end so you don't
always have to time it perfectly but it
still helps to know when they're gonna
attack and be patient and wait for it so
you can fling an arrow back at Hanzo or
get a head shot right back at
widow-makers face yep I think the best
way to start using is when you're
expecting some burst damage so that's
from McCree that happens to get close to
you that's from a bastion you could even
bait a bastion you know throw three
shuriken Xin you see it turn and face
you and then you dodge
I step back into the line of fire it
will deflect wherever your reticle is
aiming so whether that's back at Bastion
or at the support whose Healing Bastion
take your pick
aim right and you can really mess him up
and you can also deflect Ultimates so if
Zarya happens to shoot a graviton surge
into your group and your group is like
oh [ __ ] we're gonna be sucked in
together no you can deflect that and
then the other group gets sucked in and
then you guys can kill them you can also
deflect on Zoe's dragon strike arrow
before the Dragons come out if you time
it well and it'll shoot them right back
in brother those are feats of timing and
again back to that's high skills healing
that Genji has but you know when you're
first starting out working out your
Genji skills what you're going to use
mostly as a weapon is your mobility
because you can climb up walls to get to
places where people don't see you if
you're in an engagement you can double
jump the second jump is not big but it's
enough to disorient an enemy who's
picturing your trajectory going one way
and you make it go another
disorientation hitting and then running
this is like the great way to play Genji
and it does like you said like require
patience and that's the thing with his
dashing strike to it also if you kill
them with it it'll recharge right away
and you'll have it ready to rock again
this dash is really important because
not only does it let you cross gaps you
might not otherwise be able to close the
gap to enemies who are harrying or to
who you want to focus down on but it
also yeah if it kills it resets
immediately so you start to think of
Genji in terms of combos of shuriken
throws swift strikes and then also the
quick melee attack Genji is so good at
chipping down very quickly make that
quick melee attack part of your
repertoire I haven't been using it a ton
with other characters with Genji it can
really make the difference in one of his
encounters it's also really great for
flanking an opponent so if you're
staring them in the face say oh Reinhart
you can use that get a little damage on
him but you're also behind a shield when
you turn around finally his ultimate the
dragon blade pretty self-explanatory he
pulls out a giant sword and starts
chopping people up you want to target
supports and people who are squishier so
you're not wasting a lot of strikes on
maybe a heavy health tank but also keep
in mind that you can do your swift
strike and you can do your deflect in
this mode as well the swift strike
especially is key to moving around
causing chaos and chopping everyone to
bits it's also worth noting that you
might want to initiate this right before
you enter the fray because if you do in
the middle again you're squishy guy you
could be killed and wasted do it like
around a corner then come in
start taking out the Lucio's start
taking out the Rhine arts that are
blocking the objective focus on really
what your plan is and again be patient
time it and know what you're going to do
and that's the way you get into Genji
folks hopefully this guide gets you on
your way to be in the ninja badass
you've always dreamed of
moreover watch hero guides keep doing
the game spot and subscribe